Good afternoon everybody.
So thank you very much for coming to
this session today where we have the
pleasure of having Tomas Sharon to give
us a presentation on the death of the
research reports. So, um, but
uh, as we get started, uh, peace,
remember to turn off your cell
phones and all buzzing devices.
Um, so for many of you guys here
who already know Tomer, well,
welcome back to Google. For those of
you guys who don't know Tomer well,
he used to be a senior user
experience researcher here at Google.
I'm looking on the fourth floor of this
building. That's when I got to know him.
Um, so toma today is a thought leader and
a few of our user experience design and
research,
uh,
working as a vice president
and head forward hit off
user experience as we work,
which is this, a startup that has
thousands of locations worldwide, uh,
in which, uh, Tomer leads this team
that designs work and living spaces,
communities and services around
the world as we work. So, uh,
there's also a desk at a back of the
room where are copies of the most recent
book written by Tomo is on sale.
So he's the author of two books,
validating products, ideas, true
lean user research that is on sale.
Uh, also the author of a less
reasons book, uh, is our research,
which I've read and enjoyed a lot.
Uh,
and both books have a socon actually
helped to increase the adoption of user
experience research among
product teams were white.
Um, yeah, so, uh, this is how we're
going to do a two day session.
So first we would have [inaudible] up
here giving a presentation for about 20
minutes and then we would
transition to a file chats,
a discussion format between me and him.
I have some prepared questions for him,
I hope will be the same questions that
you guys have for his presentation.
And then after that we would open up a
session to Q and a from the audience.
Is that okay? Okay, great. And then
memory gets to audience Q. And. A.
I would just request that
everybody stepped up to the
mics on the both sides of
the room.
So that's all the questions that you raise
can be heard by the rest of the room.
It can also be recorded. Uh, yeah. And uh,
and we'll leave enough time so that you
guys can check out copies of his books
at a desk later, which comes with
a Google subsidized price. Okay.
So with that, uh, well welcome Toma.
Thank you Matt. It's great to be back and
it's great to see some familiar faces.
So when I joined,
we work about close to two
years ago I asked this question,
how do you decide what to work on?
And the answer to the question,
the answer that I got is pretty
much on our walls and our,
and our people's t-shirt's
do what you love. Um,
what we're trying
to do right from the guests from the get
go as we work is try and come up with
something that helps people
understand that passion.
Do what you love is not necessarily
the only way to decide what to work on.
So we added, we created this diagram
and we added human needs and ability.
So let me explain.
Passion is do what you love.
You think a product of
feature is really cool,
you're really passionate about
doing that. Uh, so you just do it.
That's how many companies
decide what to work on.
We also added ability.
Can you even do that,
that thing that you want to do and um,
and let's say that passion and ability,
sometimes you see a lot of companies
decide based on the ability as well. Uh,
and then what we wanted to add that
was completely missing at we work was
considering human needs.
Do people actually need that
thing that you're thinking of?
And it has to be what you see here.
It has to be a combination of all three
because if it's only a combination
between passion and need, then it's
fantasy. You can't, it's a flying car.
You can't really,
you can't really do it if
it's a combination between
need and ability that is
just work nine to five. There's no
passion there. And, uh, forgive me,
art lovers,
but if it's a combination between the
ability and passion than it's arth, uh,
it's not really needed, but it's
there. We're doing that anyway.
So this is, this is how, uh,
how we started a couple of
words about we work, uh,
we work as a company on a mission.
This is the company mission to create
a world where people work to make your
life not just a living.
Um, these are current,
we work cities.
Um,
I think we are in a 50 cities at the
moment with the over 160 locations and,
uh,
and we're growing,
we're opening a about 10 between
10 and 20 buildings once,
um, once every month. Um, we worked,
building we work is, is selling its
customers. We call them members, um,
space,
community and services.
So our spaces are known to be really,
really beautiful,
a really warm environment that
invites people to collaborate.
We have a lot of events that are going on,
uh,
throughout the day and
over a weekend sometimes.
And we also provide our
members with a lot of services,
a lot of digital products to support
meaningful connections between our members
and also, um, uh, apps
and so on and so forth.
Uh, to connect them services include
a health insurance if they want.
And, and probably hundreds of
other, uh, different services.
This is my group's mission design,
delightful experiences for our members
through data informed human understanding.
And here's the challenge with we work. So
think about let's say, uh, I don't know,
Steve Jobs. Um, he had
a relatively easy job.
If he wanted to understand the
user experience of apple products,
he could have said for most of them,
bring me all of Apple's products
to the table in front of me.
I want to touch them. I want to feel
them. I want to give you feedback.
This guy, this is our cofounder
and CEO, Adam Newman. Uh,
he can't do that because our
buildings are everywhere. Uh,
we're opening in more and more far
away locations and it's really,
really hard to understand
what is the user experience,
what is our members experience?
So from here,
I jumped to the research that we do.
And here are three problems
that we see with research,
uh, in companies, uh, happens here too,
happens in probably every
company that does research.
So first is bad memory.
We have bad research memory.
Um,
let me know if this scenario sounds
familiar. Other researchers here,
I know there are some. So researchers,
you don't have to say yes,
but smile if it's true.
Um,
you want to do a research activity,
some kind of study and then you just,
before you start planning,
you thinking to yourself, hmm,
maybe somebody else did it already.
So let me ask.
So you send an email to all of
the researchers in your group,
maybe in your product area,
may be all researchers at
Google. And then, uh, you ask,
did somebody do research about x?
Whatever it is that you're interested in.
And sure enough, by the end of
the day you get responses. Um,
I remember back in the day, it could go
up to 10 responses from people who say,
yes, we worked on something exactly
like that couple of years ago.
You don't get 10 responses for people
who completely forgot they did it maybe
five years ago. And then,
um, you're a nice person.
So you summarize everything you read,
you sent back to everybody.
I see some smiles. So we know
it's true, it's still true. Um,
and then you decide to do this study
anyway because yours is a little bit
different than you want to learn
something a little bit different.
So you decide to do that anyway.
So we have bad research memories.
The second problem
is silos.
Researchers are not the only ones
who are doing research in a company.
Marketing is doing research.
Product managers,
whether they call it research or not,
they are talking with a lot of users
all the time and so on and so forth.
If you have a, if you have a call
center, they don't do research,
but sometimes they issue reports about
the top 10 problems that they're facing,
uh, that, that people are calling
them about. This is also a,
a silo where this data is saved.
So a lot of departments are doing
research. Everybody's happy to share,
but there's no one place to
make sense out of all of that.
Okay.
And my pet peeve reports,
um, I'm pretty sure,
although I, I, I remember some
exceptions here at goodwill.
I'm pretty sure that there's not one
person on the face of this earth that's
wakes up in the morning saying, I'm
going to read a report today. Um,
and being a researcher for many years,
I don't even like to write them. And uh,
I think reports are not what I called
the atomic unit of a research insight.
Again,
researchers would tell you that you go
into a research study study and you have
a short list of questions you want to
answer. Those are the research questions.
And then research is life.
You look at life and life, uh,
looks at you back and say, I have
more answers. Then, uh, your question.
So you find out more than
what you intended to find.
And then there's the report. So you are,
as a researcher, you have a dilemma.
Should I report answers to the research
questions that we were interested in a
or should I report that? Plus a lot
of other information that I found.
Uh,
there's no rule about that.
So any researcher does whatever
they think is right. Uh,
in any case reports on not really atomic,
there's a report that might include a
piece of information that has nothing to
do with the reason for running this,
a specific research study.
And yet it's an important insight
that might serve people in the future,
but it's buried in the region.
Fourth,
so I'm, I'm aware of this, these
problems for many years. And, uh,
as soon as I joined we work and was
asked to start a group from scratch,
there was not a lot of research
going on there at the time. Um,
I thought this is an opportunity to
maybe solve all these problems with this
system that we called Polaris.
So,
okay.
Polaris is a way for,
um,
I call it democratize the user experience.
Uh,
I published a medium post about
that and somebody responded saying,
you're not really democratizing, why do
you call it democratizing user expensive?
You just, it's just a
research archive. So, yes,
it is a research archive,
but uh, this, uh,
that research archive is the,
uh,
the output democracy for user
experience is the outcome.
And that's really important.
What's happening with
Polaris is very interesting.
Um,
first of all,
Polaris is a system that gathers
all of the research that, uh,
that is being done at we work.
And it gathers that in a different,
very different atomic unit than a report.
I'll get to that in a second.
In any case, Polaris is helping, um,
anyone that we work who
is designing anything,
who's building anything was affecting
the member experience to prioritize their
work. And I'll give you an
example for that very shortly, um,
to educate themselves. I know, um,
that teams at,
we work as teams here and again,
researchers would, would know what I'm
talking about are not waiting for anyone.
They're not waiting for a researcher
or for report or for a study to end to
decide what to do or to
decide what to work on.
That said they are happy to learn and
educate themselves about what they decided
to do already.
So Polaris is a system that helps educate
these teams about what they're working
on.
And lastly,
if by any chance there's a
team was looking for a project,
Polaris can help allocate or assign
teams with different projects.
All right, when I talked about the
atomic unit of a research insight,
this is, this is it a, we call
it a research nugget. And uh,
we just celebrated a,
a little while ago, uh,
5,000 nuggets entered to Polaris
in a chicken nugget meal. Um,
so what's the nugget and I get is a
tagged observations supported by evidence
tagged observation,
supported by evidence.
I'll explain observation.
So observation is something that
we learned during the study.
We saw something,
we understood something,
we understood why it happened. This is
an observation. So we just type it down.
This is what we found and this
is what explains it. Evidence.
There has to be,
there's no nugget.
Nothing enters Polaris without evidence.
It's not about the opinion of anyone.
There has to be evidence proof that
the observation that true is true.
That could be, um, a short video
clip. It could be 10 seconds.
It could be a minute, something
like that. It could be a photo,
it could be a screenshot of an email,
it could be a document,
it can be whatever it is,
whatever media.
But proof and evidence that what we said
in the observation is a actually what
happened. And lastly, and
that's what makes Polaris, um,
useful in special is a series of tags.
The first thing we did when we designed
Polaris was created a long taxonomy of
tags. How we tag things, how we tag
nuggets, uh, within that system.
So these could be, um,
tags that are pretty, uh,
pretty much demographic.
Uh,
so which city and name of the location,
uh,
the size of the company and so on that,
that the person is representing
and so on and so forth.
But there are also tags that
relate to the experience.
So is this observation of
positive one neutral or negative?
Is this, um, what is
the magnitude of that?
What is the frequency and
so on and so forth. Um,
I call them the three Cs. Three
things that people can, uh,
can do in Polaris when they go into the
system. They can create the nuggets.
All right? They can search for different
nuggets under different topics and,
and um,
and create playlists from these nuggets.
They can. And this is how it looks
like. So you see, uh, an interview here.
So we just decide on the
clip, uh, what is the,
what is the length and the minute, the
second that it starts and ends, uh,
and that would be the evidence.
If that's a,
an interview you see a middle left to see,
uh,
an empty box for typing
down the observation, uh,
and under right and bottom left
you see some of the tags, uh,
that we're using. Um, we tagged
by journey, we tanked by emotions,
objects and the experience
metrics that I just described.
And then, uh, you can also cure it.
You can add and create a playlist
and nuggets to playlists. Um,
and you can share these with
other people at we work.
Uh, this is how I played
us a look. Looks like, um,
you might suspect they worked
here for awhile. Um, so, uh,
what you see, uh,
obviously the video is, uh,
the evidence just below it. You see other
members squatting, blah, blah, blah.
That's the observation and some of
the tags on the right hand side,
on the bottom right hand side and
on the right is the playlist itself,
the different nuggets that
compile and create the playlist.
You can see that you have nine
nuggets there that will take you five,
about five minutes to watch and so on.
People can consume,
um,
consumed these nuggets and playlists.
I compared that to a
healthy food at first. Uh,
they don't really like it, but it's
good for them. So they have to, um,
and in time they understand that this
is useful and they use it more and more.
We see very interesting,
um, usage scenarios, uh,
tracking what's happening behind the
scenes. Um, we see people who are,
let's say there's a designer,
interior designer that designed, um,
a conference room at we work.
So that person is looking for a
feedback about conference room. Uh,
we see people in building, in a
building. We saw somebody in a,
in Chicago watching all 200 nuggets
related to that building in Chicago.
Uh, and so on and so forth. We've
seen teams are making decisions,
roadmap decisions about their products
based on what they find in Polaris.
I want to give you an example for that.
Um,
so to become a, we work member,
uh, you usually take a tour.
If you take a tour, you go through the
building you were interested in, uh,
they show you different things and then
you decide if you want to join or not.
Uh, we also serve coffee and we work. Uh,
so let's say you are the general manager
of we work in Europe and you want to
see, um, do you want to
get feedback about tours?
You want to understand the
situation about tours and coffee,
what's more important? You
search for negative, um,
tours in Amsterdam or
sorry, in Europe. Um,
and then you might get a dish
results 72 nuggets in the playlist.
And when you search for
coffee negative in Europe,
you get three nuggets. That
alone, without even watching the,
the playlists,
that alone tells you that there might
be a bigger challenge there with tours
rather than coffee. So your
focus should be on, on, uh,
understanding what's happening with tours.
Okay.
I want to show you a quick
video of how it looks
like and sounds like. So,
uh,
we also serve be year.
So here's some feedback about beer.
Oops.
Okay.
So you first,
this is how you start the search. You
search, these are, we call them props.
So beer is a prop. Uh, you search,
you select a location.
If you're interested in some other
filters, you apply them. If not,
you move on and you get the results as a,
as a playlist,
you can save it.
Okay.
I have a very creative,
a name for this very creative description
and
let's listen to a couple
of, uh, of nuggets
having other than a [inaudible] over here.
[inaudible] that to me,
I'm no art,
but
not everybody likes beer though.
Yeah.
Or the fact of having beer in an office.
It was noisy and they, I think,
you know, not everybody's twice.
If I'm having people come
off and, you know, yeah, it's
a cool face everyday, but,
you know, having kids drink
beer and all that crap is fine,
but I think there's a whole nother niche
for a little bit more sophisticated. Uh,
minorities or people in Ad Tech,
right?
So this is how it looks
like and sounds like.
I obviously pick the audio not to
expose the identity of those people.
Um, you can also watch a list,
um, a playlist as a list,
not just as a,
as a videos or photos and
of course,
no, no, no.
Sorry about that.
Okay.
All right. Um, and to sum it up,
this is division for Polaris
because this is not the end. What,
what Polaris before I show you that
what Belarus is doing is tell you,
uh, tell us we work employees, uh,
why things aren't happening.
Our vision is also to provide
a system that tells us,
that explains what is happening.
So we want to provide a score
for everything at we work
a quantitative score and
then from that score lead to a
Polaris playlists. So for example,
beer, um, let's say beer
is scoring a worldwide,
there was a,
the score is 44% out of 100.
And you want to understand as the person
who's responsible for beer, do we work?
You want to understand
why the score is so low.
Then you can get, um,
get to Polaris and see a,
a playlist of people talking
about, um, about beer.
The way we do that is by collecting,
for example, satisfaction feedback,
uh, through these little devices
that we created on the top left.
And we put them everywhere
in the building, um,
through surveys and through an
APP. We call this the APP, uh,
through an APP that our
teams in the buildings, uh,
pull out and ask people to rate different
things that are happening around them.
So this is,
uh,
how people can understand both what is
happening and then understand why it's
happening. Uh, I couldn't help it,
but, uh, if, if you're interested,
this is a, this is another research
project that we completed it,
we work,
we found that a lot of people don't
show up to tours because they,
uh, can't find the entrance to the
building. So this is how we, uh,
how we solved it.
So you can read about it there and I think
we are done. Yeah. Slide, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Bottom this deck, if you're
interested. And second to last,
if you want to start it on your own,
just check it out and see if there's
something that you can do. We created a,
an air table template,
uh,
for Polaris for designing your
own Polaris. So feel free to,
um, to use it. Um, I think that's it.
Thank you.
Okay. Hey, great.
Thank you so much for taking the
time to explain this. And, uh,
I was not expecting to have place that
we could use to starts putting together
something like this together. So, um,
well, so some questions for you. So,
uh, if we had to think about, you know,
pull that reason and all
these processes from the con,
the producers and false starts,
uh,
it seems to me that there's
a bit of this assymetry.
Where are the people who are trying to
put all these nuggets into the system or
the guys are putting in all the hard
work so that the consumers could actually
benefit from this. So, um, so
I mean, so in your experience,
what have been some of the, you know, the,
the socon more successful ways to
actually incentivize more people in your
organization to create a
and archive these nuggets?
So at this point I would say we are
kind of a control freaks about, uh,
what's going on,
what goes in a Polaris
outside the UX team.
Not a lot of people can, can
add nuggets to Polaris. Uh,
there are exceptions though.
The exceptions are a team that asked
us specifically to train them on.
It's actually a,
it's kind of a hidden way of training
teams on how to do their own research.
They want to add things to
Polaris and we say, you know what,
let's train you on how to do research.
You'll do research.
And then we're also training on how to
add nuggets to the system. And then,
and then they do that. So we, so
far trained to, uh, different teams.
Sometimes there's a person that is,
you know,
an individual that's interested
personally in, in doing that,
we train them as well. But
not everyone is, is, uh,
has access to do that. Okay,
great. That's interesting.
And that actually leads me to
the next question. Uh, you know,
because you were talking about all
these things about observations versus
evidence. Yeah. Well, I mean, what does it
actually take to train someone, you know,
to, to actually, uh,
so called Freeman and does something that
is acceptable as a piece of evidence.
Uh, we have conversations with the Ux
team about many things related to Polaris
specifically about that as well.
It really depends.
If you don't say anything,
some people would write
down and observation and
then choose as evidence the
exact same words that the person in the
interview is saying, for example. Um,
so we asked them and train them to kind
of add some more context by extending
the time that they, uh, as evidence. Uh,
sometimes it's not just a recording,
sometimes it's a photo and support that
with a photo that better explains or
provides evidence to what you were
just saying. Um, it's not easy.
Um, we have a lot of
conversations about the quality,
what qualifies as a great nugget.
And so on. We also have a term,
a kind of internal Tammy,
you don't see it in the system.
We call it the golden nugget.
A golden nugget is a nugget that is so
special that you learned something really
important from it.
It's really actionable.
It's something that we say it's like
a headbanger. It's like, Oh man,
we have to do something about that.
Um, how many percent of your nuggets?
Golden Nuggets. Oh, very few.
Very, very few. Okay. Yeah.
So I was wondering,
you know, because yeah,
it's that he's a sudden trash whole
data piece of evidence needs to meet.
So, um, so with those
situations when, you know,
there might be t employees who actually
disagree about the evidence that go into
nuggets or sometimes the fact that
the evidence might be okay in itself,
but it's not relevant to the observation.
So what are you guys,
what I'm going to say didn't happen yet.
We didn't implement this,
but this is something
that we're working on. Um,
as we train new people and
adding a nuggets and evidence to,
to Polaris, uh, we want to
great different roles of people.
And then if you are a kind of a Newbie,
a nugget Isare we call it,
then,
uh,
then somebody will have to review and
approve your maybe first 100 nuggets.
So there's another eye that looks
at things. It's not just you.
So we hope to somehow compensate for
things that don't count as evidence for
example. Okay. Yeah. And
then, well, as you mentioned,
in order to know how good is the most
atomic units of research findings,
but sometimes our consumers
don't really once, uh, two,
two cats finding at that
level of granularity,
they want something like a higher level
team that integrates and synthesizes
many different nuggets. So do
you guys provide any support
for that? Right now? Uh,
we create,
we also create and curate playlists.
So these are UX create a curated playlist
and we shared them with teams so we
can do their work. We have a way to,
it's like, in a way, it's like a report,
but it's a playlist with, uh,
maybe a few more words about it,
some analysis into what is it that you're,
you're seeing in the playlist
and so on. So we do that. Um,
and, and sometimes we train others
to do that as well. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So now switching over to the
consumer side of things. Um,
so what have you guys found to be the
types and characteristics of research
nuggets that were more
useful to consumers? So I,
I touched a little bit
earlier. Um, sometimes nuggets,
and these are the nuggets is
that people who enter them, um,
they just in an observation that
just describe what happened. Uh,
that's not true. Not
really useful. So, uh,
the person said that beer is having
beer in an office is not a good idea.
That's not enough. As, as a nugget,
we want to understand why or they held
a me maybe describe something more
meaningful.
Um,
the members said that they're taking
meetings in a coffee shop rather than in
our conference rooms.
Interesting. But still,
it's not a nugget because
we don't understand why. Um,
and if they add the why, for example,
they do that because we work as too noisy.
Then we have something that
we can do something about.
So, uh, this is meaningful.
This is something that hints
that there's a problem there.
And we know what the problem is and if
we search for noise and certainly if it's
tagged by noise and conference rooms,
and if we search for that,
for lifts like that in Polaris and
see, I don't know, 120 nuggets,
we know we have a problem there that
we need to do something about. Uh,
so these nuggets must be,
um,
kind of a unit and atomic unit
and it's not an atomic unit if,
if it doesn't have that,
why? Okay. Got It. Yeah.
So some product questions now because man,
uh,
understanding an impression about Polaris
when watching our presentation is that
there's always a pension in computing
systems between poo and push mechanisms.
Uh, Polaris seems to be something
that's more pool driven.
Yep. Uh, and you know, if,
well,
what might be some opportunities to think
about supporting more push mechanisms.
So currently we have a
manual push mechanism.
We push lists to people.
We heard you've been working
on ordering beer for, we work.
Here's a playlist of, of people, uh,
members from all of the world talking
about beer. Uh, that's very manual.
Um, one other thing that that's
a feature can have an on our,
on our roadmap, um, is uh,
updating you as somebody who either showed
some kind of interest in a playlist.
Either you created it or
it was shared with you. Um,
each time there's a new nugget that is
being added to the list and it's being
added automatically because of the tags,
you'll get a notification about that.
And then we hope that this will
encourage people to try it out more.
That's a great ideal. You know, as soon
as you were talking about tagging, um,
I was wondering when you guys
were designing Polaris, uh,
besides attacking approach,
were there any other considerations
that you guys considered for other
approaches to organizing
the nuggets? Uh, no,
not really. Um, the only
thing we were not sure of, we,
it was very clear for us
that this was an investment.
So we wanted to be sure that this is
working before we kind of make that
investment. So we created that template
that I shared. We created everything, uh,
with air table,
um,
stored everything on the video recordings,
on Youtube store,
audio recordings on soundcloud.
And that was our system.
Um, as soon as we saw the reaction
to it, um, we decided, okay,
this is worthwhile. And then
we invested the time in, um,
changing all of that to a system
that we can control and okay.
That makes total sense to me.
Um,
well what are some of the challenges to
scaling something that Polaris and what
are you guys doing about that?
Um,
so I would say there are two
challenges that are kind of related.
One is that it needs to be something that,
that people like we work are aware of.
Cause if they're not aware of it,
obviously they're not going to use it.
And the other challenge is once they
are aware and they search for something,
they have to see.
I don't know if you noticed the dates,
they have to see nuggets
that are relatively new.
Otherwise they think it's an old,
uh,
database of information and they're
not going to do anything about it.
Although we all know that sometimes,
uh,
even if you found something a year or
two ago, it doesn't mean that it's old.
It doesn't, it doesn't mean that it's
not true, but that's how people treat it.
So we, our challenge is
to keep it fresh. Um,
and these are the challenges
because to keep it fresh,
it means that more people need to
do research and nuggetize that, um,
more and more. And that's something
that we don't always have time to do.
And awareness is, is
again, always a challenge.
We need to push and talk about it
and mentioned it in every meeting.
When somebody asks us a question, we
shouldn't just answer, we should say.
And that's what we try and do
and remember ourselves to do.
Have you checked out Polaris?
Do you know what the virus is?
Maybe show them and then they start
using it on their own? Yeah, I mean,
do you guys have, I
mean, at a system level,
you actually have a way to
designate certain of those
nuggets as golden nuggets.
So that it stuff, it's just
a jargon between, yeah.
Um, so what are some of the considerations
around personally identifiable
information? I mean, I saw that
you guys had to, uh, you know,
just blackout the faces and that's, that's
only for the presentation. But yeah,
uh, that's a, that's a challenge. I mean,
we covered the identity of the
person itself. So the member,
the company name is not it,
it's,
it's a kind of a encrypted throats code.
And uh,
the same for the person's name. We
don't even add it to the system. Um,
that said, if you are, our people in the
buildings are called community teams.
If you're a community manager and you see
a video of a member from your building,
you would know them. Even though you have
a thousand members, you would know them.
So are always concerned with
people taking it the wrong way,
especially if the feedback or
the nugget is talking about you,
the community manager.
So we ask the people we talk with,
not to mention names. So just
say, so we say, for example,
if you have feedback about,
uh, your community manager,
use that term. My community
managers don't use a name. Um,
they don't always follow instructions,
but we tried.
You guys do about evidence if they don't
follow instructions. Uh, so it's, it's,
it's something we have to cut and, and,
and, and not include. Cause that's a,
we don't want people to use it as,
you know,
I saw you saying something bad about
me. Why are you doing that? Um,
that's always a challenge. But at
least the name and the company name,
they're not included in Polaris. They
can, they can see that. Okay. Yeah.
So going I think to more broader
organizational wide issues. I mean,
what do you see as some of the necessary
conditions that need to be in place for
organizations to actually adopt your
ideas around Polaris effectively?
Um, honestly, uh,
I, I, I couldn't care less. I mean,
it's really,
honestly,
I'll tell you that when I described
Polaris to important people that we work,
I was asked not to do it before we did it.
Um,
this is something that, uh, I'm
sure other researchers here are,
um, not foreign to the problems
that I described. A, this is,
these are problems that are
happening for many years.
In many companies and it was very clear
to us that this is something that we
work with benefit from.
So if the company is doing research
or is beginning to do research,
it's relevant. Other considerations,
I think everything is solvable.
We have challenges with
making people aware of it,
but that's something we need to deal with.
This is what the company needs.
This is the healthy food they needed,
although it's not tasty at first. Okay.
Well,
so do you know of any other organizations
that have already adopted your ideas
around Polaris? Uh,
since we made it public,
a lot of companies contacted us. Uh, I
don't really know if they implemented it,
but um, all of Google's
competitors, uh, kept in touch.
I have no idea if, if they do anything
about it, but there's interest,
I don't really know. Wow. Okay.
And I think that as a way to encourage
us to try to adopt some of these ideas.
I'll be honest, I tried here, but,
uh, I didn't get a lot of traction.
Um,
I think what you see here is a,
and we talked about it earlier,
you see research archives and these
research archives that you see here,
our archives that you can just
upload your report and uh,
maybe tagging, I can't
remember. Oh, sure. Um,
I think it's not enough. It's not,
it's not atomic enough. And, um,
and when you're tagging your not and
you're thinking about the entire study of
thinking about the entire report,
the reports are long include many things
and the insights as I described earlier
and so on. So I would say, uh,
no you don't have it and um,
maybe it's an opportunity. Okay.
Well,
uh,
so we have 15 minutes left and I just
wanted to make sure that members of the
audience get to ask any
questions that you guys have.
So we have mice on the two
ends of the room. Free,
free to just step out and ask her
questions so that the rest of the room can
hear your questions.
Okay.
I'm in an organization that loves research
reports and I'd love to know a little
bit besides just developing a tool,
how you weaned people off
of their dependency on it.
Why, why do they love the reports?
I'm sure they don't have reports.
They love the research because it's known.
Yeah.
There like familiar so familiar
way that they're used to.
You're talking about the researchers
or, or uh, the consumers of research,
consumers of research, internal,
internal clients of research.
I,
to me the biggest insult as a researcher
is when people read the report and they
say, hmm, interesting. Um,
I want it to be actionable and um,
I think that if you track and
see, I'm not gonna, I'm gonna,
I'm not gonna you know,
really you hear,
but are they doing anything with
these risk research reports?
If the answer is no or not really or
not, you know, what you expected, then,
uh, I would say don't listen
to what they say about reports,
look at their behavior as you
know, and uh, treat them as users.
This is a design challenge and see
what you can do about it. Well,
Iris is not the only answer, I'm sure.
Uh, it's just one possible answer.
If reports worked for them and
you're happy and they're happy,
don't find them off of that.
Okay.
Take some air for your presentation
I think is super interesting.
And of course as a researcher,
I'm always looking for any tool that can
help us not only capture feedback but
also communicate it with my stakeholders.
I noticed one of the images that
you had or you have a device,
a physical device, one of the phone
rooms. Yeah. So two questions.
One is, um, how does it work?
How is this connected
to Polaris and second,
why using a physical device instead
of sending a survey to your,
um,
to the consumer?
Very, very, very good question.
So, um, the product that is,
we work is, has many, many details, many,
many things that create it. Um, we think
it's hundreds of hundreds of things.
It's the beer and it's the,
the chairs and it's the, the,
the wallpaper and the events and the
community team and so many other things.
It doesn't make any sense to ask
about 500 things. In a survey,
uh, nobody would complete it. Um,
that's one reason we don't
solely use surveys for, uh,
for these, uh, quantitative
measurements. Um,
we also know that especially for
physical things and objects and spaces,
the best way to collect
feedback is there in context.
So imagine a, a conference room.
So you booked a conference room.
Let's say the next time
you book a conference room,
you have a popup question on
your screen that asks you, uh,
how has your recent experience with
the conference room you just, um,
you used maybe five days
ago. Uh, we have that,
but we learned from
members that in many cases,
first they don't remember
how was the experience. Uh,
and two, they, uh, the person
who is booking the room,
it's not necessarily the person who is
using it. So the feedback is very biased.
So in context is the best
because we know you're there,
we know you just use the room, give us
your feedback. And that's it. That said,
it's not connected to Polaris.
Uh,
this is a different system that gathers
all this data about a scoring different
spaces and other things.
And then you get a score for different
things and locations and regions.
And so on.
From there,
we take that and we link that with a
relevant Polaris or we would that's not
connected yet. That's the vision. Connect
that to a Polaris playlist, as I said.
So if you see the data about beer is
flowing to and creating that score in a
dashboard somewhere,
uh, and then that score,
you'll have a link next to it that we'll
connect you to a playlist about beer in
Polaris. And these devices are based
on, we created them. It's uh, these are,
uh, Amazon dash buttons and the
casing is something we designed.
Okay.
Uh,
so one of the things that
reports sometimes we'll do
is give you the background
of the research that happens and
action items that happen afterwards.
How do you see your tool taking into
account when significant change or impact
has already come from
the nuggets that exist?
So that's says democracy.
I'm talking about,
I'm almost eliminating the
researcher from the equation here.
I want the person who is watching the,
creating the playlist,
watching it and deciding what to do next.
I want them to create that for themselves.
They decide,
they know what happened before,
they know about the background and they
know what they can learn from what they
just saw. The researcher is
there to help them. I want my,
my idea is that everyone's a researcher.
I want everyone to do that.
Currently we're kind of in
a transition mode where, uh,
researchers and other Ux people are
contributing or adding nuggets to Polaris.
But as the consumer of
it, let's say a, um,
that's equated to what's happening here
at product manager or an engineering
team or, or whoever is deciding,
uh, something about a product.
I see them as the ones that
almost write these for themselves.
It doesn't have to be in writing,
has to be an understanding that they
have what they know, what this, uh,
what this can help them with,
what decisions they can take based on
that and so on. There's no, that's,
that's exactly what the democracy I
talked about. Um, it's not, uh, you know,
at least when we use Polaris,
the way I'm describing it, uh,
those decisions are not in the hands of,
um,
researchers to write in a report.
This is in the hands of consumers,
people who are actually designing
what to do with the products.
One quick followup I guess.
Yeah.
You prevent duplicate research from
happening around her at the same time.
So say if a community manager in Chicago,
it goes through some nuggets and on
beer and decides to take action based on
those nuggets. And then a community
manager here does the same thing.
Does it duplicate the work or do you
think they're just building on top of each
other?
So when it comes to what we call
consumables, beer, coffee, and so on,
it's not that every building is deciding.
Not always. Every building is deciding,
deciding what to buy. It's
being centralized. So it's
not really about them. Uh,
but if two different people decide
to improve the member experience,
that's a good thing. That didn't
happen before. So that's a good thing.
I don't see that as a problem. Consistency
is not necessarily a must always.
Hi. I actually had a similar question and
just to follow up some curious, are Ken,
those community managers actually
track that so they're aware of what's
happening and what's track
what the outcomes are,
actions taken based on the nuggets?
Uh, not in Polaris. No.
So you can't necessarily see how
someone else, no, you're fine.
Do you think that's important or no?
Um, I think we work as a lot
of systems in place for, uh,
for doing that.
We're not trying,
I think it's important that we're
not trying to solve that with,
with Polaris we thought about kind of,
we thought about adding a feature which
was there for maybe two minutes and then
we removed that of kind of allowing
people who use a certain playlist that
indicates a certain problem to raise
their hand digitally in the system as
people want to be a part of a
team that solves the problem. Um,
but then we were afraid that Polaris
is going to be become a kind of a,
instead of a research tool, it's
going to be a project management tool.
So we stop there.
Okay.
Okay. Hi, uh,
so any evidence on how this has changed,
uh,
research reports that we work?
Is it dead?
It changed resource
reports because we just don't
write them. Yeah. I'm curious how,
how has that changed the culture?
It's for, you know, anything
that happens in my group,
we don't write research reports. It's
really, really hard for some people,
but we're overcoming that.
Um,
and instead of writing a research
report that if we really have the urge,
we just create a playlist and then,
uh,
if we want to add things that
we would have added to a report,
we added as a feature
request for Polaris and, and,
and we make that happen if
it's really, really needed.
Um, that makes us, you know,
we ask ourselves very hard
questions sometimes. Uh, what
is evidence? For example,
do we really need, so
there was one request, uh,
to add multiple files as evidence.
Do we really need three photos that show
the same thing from different angles?
Not always a, do we need a photo
combined with an audio file?
Maybe. Um, and so on. But yeah, for a,
yeah.
Anything related to my group, we don't,
we don't write research reports. Uh,
the hardest thing by the way is by,
you know, when we share that with,
uh, executives that are
used to reading reports,
uh, it's sometimes a process and
education is involved in, you know,
communicating that this is a report, this
playlist, this is the report. That's it.
Okay.
Just a followup question. Yep. So, um,
in terms of decision making
and how do you prevent,
um,
product manager,
sort of decision makers to take what
users said at what the community says at
face value without like photo there,
um,
analysis or maybe without checking the
golden nuggets and you were imagining.
So,
uh,
I'm sure you know that what users say
that is the solution to their problem is
in many cases not the solution
to the problem. So we,
you exercise know that. So we don't even
include that in, in, uh, in the nuggets.
So they won't see that.
Um, it is a process.
This is why we work with these teams.
It is a process to teach people and mentor
people on how to make sense out of a
playlist. And, uh, I should say, I mean,
even for a very basic, um,
I dunno, usability tests,
if you put people in a room or watch
videos, whatever, who are not researchers,
not your Xers,
never seen a usability test.
They see videos of people
using their product.
After an hour of watching
these day, we'll have, uh,
enough information to come
up with decisions on what
to change in the product.
And these will be very good decisions
and in 99% of the cases. So I'm not,
I'm not concerned about that
at all. Okay. My last question,
you have researchers make or do you
have researchers making the editorial
decisions about what's worth putting in?
So if you have a steady three out of five,
four and a five for one
and a five run into this,
do you pick one that's representative
and put that in as a problem and flag it?
Do you put all three in combined?
What does that look like?
Most of the nuggets that go into Polaris
or not of not coming from studies,
they're coming with ongoing conversations
and interviews we have with members
mostly with, um, uh,
we call them graduating members with
members and decided to leave us. Um,
we, we think not because they're
pissed at us necessarily.
We think this is a good time,
uh,
for us to talk with them because they
understand what's worked well at we work
and what works not so well. It's
we work. So this is not a study.
This is something we do all
the time and it's, it's,
it's almost never a one at a five,
two out of five,
three out of five thing that
comes to play when you search for,
uh,
for nuggets and create playlists.
So that's the example I gave with
the tours and, and, and coffee. Um,
you see three nuggets.
That's your three. That's it.
That's evidence that the only three
nuggets about bad coffee, I don't know,
then probably it's not
a problem. Um, and, um,
it's very rarely that
we, I mean, not rarely,
but we sometimes do these studies and
then we just don't take it as one of the
five. They had a fight. We just look at,
let's say an interview or
observation or whatever it is,
and we just derived these nuggets and
that's it. And then they go into Polaris,
into the ether, and then anyone can
search and create whatever they want,
but then, hmm, okay. Yeah. I just
want to antibiotic treatment.
It's been 40 hours.
So that does enough time for interested
folks who checkouts copies of his book
behind. So we bet, uh,
please join me in thanking [inaudible]
once again for joining us today.
Excellent.